this is five molar Grable's short
graybles short graybles um we all kind
of got it as a collective actually which
was kind of cool cuz like and knowing
what the answer was made me giggle yes I
thought it was the same thing of course
I I said you know okay well I'm thinking
something with fingers or you know like
feed you know digits or something like
that
I've seen more sort of like hands or
something and then Jory said yeah I'm
thinking something with fingers I'm
really thinking fingers and then Bree
was like wait a minute
raising the pinkie you know then the
ring finger and the pointing finger it's
all five fingers that were like yeah I
think that's gotta be it and of course
at the end they say nobody has five
fingers everybody has four fingers um
you know this was actually the 510 you
see you know it's like Oh while they're
technically there it's like it's there
yeah I mean but like I don't even
quote-on-quote five tastes well no it's
not five tastes it's just five different
tastes yeah just that there's five
different tastes good because he got you
emo Philips got you well I think it was
an intentional sort of got you sort of
thing like they're very obviously a look
at the fingers had something else no I
think I think you guys are just foolish
and I won't say this one when he said
the five taste he's going through and
I'm listening to this I'm like no no
they gotta be trolling us cuz that
finger thing is like ingenious you know
it's like that's way too much of a
coincidence and it's like what you
thought was the five five fingers four
five four hundred million rubles yeah so
good like that so uh so I like that I
like that there's a good you know
there's a twist to it um
the stories were all funny and I gotta
say it's just after three I didn't even
know like four episodes that were mostly
like you know either heavy or depressing
or or creepy or you know just out of the
norm whatever it's nice just to kind of
have just here's a fun waste of time
again yeah yeah because that was like
four episodes in a row where every time
you see it just go
she's so even though the one before this
was funny it's still wrapping up you
know this very you know
sorry heavy storyline yeah so no I
thought was fun I thought it was the
jokes were clever it it has a lot of my
favorite characters they have cause I
love tree trunks I love Marceline and
Ice King and stuff so I made BMO it's
great to see people who now think she's
a little girl I guess now like how it
keeps changing which she calls football
right is that what she calls the
reflection it's like yeah it's like
football and football yeah that yeah so
so I like that a lot and yeah it's just
sort of a basic good funny episode um
not not too much else like oh I love the
design of the rock guy that points a
Marceline in the right director I love I
love it was playing the drum set you
know is that the ice King's drums that
look like you know I get two different
drum set by the matter on drum sets look
the same
that's racist well they were the same
color though so it's even more races
yeah my friends because I'm the asshole
friend
oh so yes I like to play the drums with
his fingers Oh about that very funny oh
so uh ya know just a generally good
episode about you I was fine with it
yes it will be hating on tree trunks
sister finances not actually tree trunks
this time around it was actually it felt
like there's Finn and Jake's which I
really love how they it's a warlocks
book and it goes all dark and creepy
while they're doing boy I love that the
Marceline one was just too fast
yeah I like a little more with that but
then the tree trunks one was too long
like that one that's was my problem with
it was it just stretched out way too
long and then you got the Ice King one
which I thought was a pretty decent
amount and same with what's my call it
BMO it just seemed like to me and I
could just because I'm not a fan of tree
trunks you know it just seemed like it
was stretched out a bit I will say if I
if I could go back and change something
I would probably do that Nick
Marceline's a little longer tree trunks
a little shorter
they're already really short obvious oh
yeah but yeah I actually would probably
change that round a touch um I did love
Marceline's look though I'm involved
like her looks so far for some reason
this is the one that I look at it like I
really like that look on her
you mean expression or what she's
wearing just like her hair her what
she's wearing at everything it actually
seems to fit her some of the because
she's consistently changing outfits in a
lot of times of my god god what is wrong
with you you know Angie that is
something that this cartoon show does
you know that has these very fantasy
world it can just anything we can do we
can sort of do sort of thing where that
actually is surplus that they do a lot
of characters do actually change outfits
around a little bit you know I'm not
many I mean but they still will change
that aaj especially Marceline in
people's yeah I think those aren't you
the two that jump the most of mind
um maybe nobody else the more I think so
maybe it's not that many characters
maybe it's just more fully them not many
characters were close yeah I guess
that's true to a peppermint Palmer he
could change his clothes around or
something go to luck peppermint Butler
I'm not I'm just saying his mother
probably steak do not mock peppermint
Butler not mocking peppermint going down
the dark path you never go down math
back that well after he launched I'm
gonna make fun of them even more um so
if I come back missing an arm
and suddenly its robotic but it doesn't
make sense how it works I just did that
for fun he had nothing to do with it so
um yeah just any final thoughts on this
alone there don't mock and you can't
people my god
or Butler's that are made of peppermint
who also have robotic arms it's too you
know bro not mocking advocate do it
quite pologize for you or I I you you're
the one saying they know how it worked
yeah but then I thought about like a
little actually if you know you can
dislodge and plug it back are you being
just what are you distracted by now
um I'm looking at you you're looking up
and okay there is a screensaver over
there that has a lot of people with one
arm threatening to kill me right now so
you know they caught my attention a
little bit you know new spreads fast on
the internet so there it is peppermint
Butler sucks bye